good morning Hank it's Monday this giant
squid of anger is reading my collected
works you'll never guess what came in
the mail today unless you guess it's The
Fault in Our Stars oh this is the real
book one of the few unsigned copies
actually on the back it has quotes from
Markus Zusak and Jodi Pico and a la
carte Markus Zusak says The Fault in Our
Stars is John Green at his best you
laugh you cry and then you come back for
more Thank You Markus Zusak more
importantly thank you for writing The
Book Thief that was nice of you it's the
real book gank it has all the pages in
it and everything so I do you know about
gaymans law gaymans law invented by Neil
Gaiman holds that if an author opens a
book he or she wrote he or she will
inevitably come across a typo of course
gaymans law holds again I think the only
typo in the entire book is in the
author's note but I found it immediately
anyway hit that reminded me that typos
are among my fields of expertise so I
thought I would share with you my top
five typos of all time oh god it smells
so good number five the pasta Bible Hank
this is a totally normal book about
pasta except that it contains a typo so
horrific that the publisher found every
copy it could and destroyed them there
was recipe for tagliatelle in the book
that called for salt and ground black
people they meant to pepper but the
federal people remember for the entire
name Imogen the name Imogen comes from
the Shakespeare play Cymbeline and it's
probably a transcription error
Shakespeare probably meant Imogen which
was a name at the time but when they
wrote it down those ends got a really
close together and became an m' and bam
we have Imogen Heap whose name is based
on a typo number three I'm cheating
because this is not from a book it's
from a newspaper but it's my favorite
headline ever from the Washington Post
FDR in bed with co-ed cold they meant
cold but they wrote co-ed FDR was so
delighted about this that he asked for
hundred copies but sadly they had
already been pulped this is particularly
funny because Franklin Delano Roosevelt
did have a lot of affairs although never
with a co-ed but you know this was back
in the days when newspapers reported
news number two
the United States Constitution article 1
section 10 Hank no State shall without
the consent of Congress lay any impose
or duties on imports or exports except
what may be absolutely necessary for
executed
it's its inspection laws Hank when you
write its if you are contracting it is
yes if you are not contracting it is no
I mean seriously Hank amendment 28
should be we acknowledge that earlier in
this very Constitution we screwed up its
in its and we are sorry and number one
the Bible so Hank in 1631 two printers
were tasked with making a new King James
Bible and they did a great job
except when they were doing the seventh
commandment they forgot a knot so their
Bible said thou shalt commit adultery as
you can imagine eight this didn't go
over particularly well the Archbishop of
Canterbury said I knew the time when
great care was had about printing Bibles
especially so their to go and people
have been declaring the decline of good
proofreading for five centuries and the
guys who made the mistake we're fined as
were the guys who made the 17:16 version
of the King James Bible in which Jesus
encourages an adulterous woman go and
sin on more supposed to be go and sin no
more so yeah so that's my list which
pretty much I created solely so that I
could say you know forgive me for any
mistakes if you want to pre-order your
signed copy of The Fault in Our Stars
there are links in the doobly-doo to do
so Hank I will see you on Wednesday